la emigración tema clave del cara a cara
y le propuso un referendo para ver si
los franceses están de acuerdo con dejar
entrar a los refugiados
la inmigración anárquica y masiva
contribuye a la grabación de la
inseguridad en nuestro país esa es la
razón por la cual voy a proponerle a los
franceses un referéndum de estos
seguramente hablaremos más adelante para
con el fin de cambiar radicalmente la
política de inmigración para que al fin
simplemente los franceses decidan quién
puede venir quien se puede quedar y
quién se debe ir
propuso además una prohibición total del
hiyab el velo islámico algo que más ron
crítico
hay en nuestro país un islamismo que en
mi opinión no ha sido
un club combatido con las políticas que
usted ha establecido entonces hay que
poner una ley contra la ideología
islamista pienso que no hemos sido lo
suficientemente firmes en este tema yo
estoy por a favor de la interdicción del
uso del velo en el espacio público ya lo
he dicho claramente pienso que el velo
es un uniforme
primero que todo los escucho y lo dice
con mucha claridad una demostración pero
lo que me preocupa en su demostración es
el camino que toma
sobre un tema sobre el velo llevó al
terrorismo para volver al islamismo y
para ir a los extranjeros y usted crea
un sistema de equivalencias en este
camino que confunde todos los problemas
y que los mantienen lepén aprovechó para
cuestionar las políticas sobre el manejo
de la pandemia del gobierno de macrón
uno de los puntos que se le critican el
presidente de cara a estas elecciones